merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre madame la ministre
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
il y a un an à quelques jours près la
France ouvrait les portes du Panthéon à
Joséphine Baker 6e femme à y prendre
place après Simone Veil elle est
l'incarnation d'une intégration voulue
et réussie grand artiste de music hall
humaniste et femme de cœur elle fut
avant tout une grande patriote
sous-lieutenant engagé au sein des
Forces françaises libres et lorsqu'elle
était félicitée pour pour son action
elle répondait la France m'a ouvert les
bras je ne fais que lui rendre ce
qu'elle m'a donné par cette introduction
je souhaitais rappeler que nombre
d'autres Joséphine existent même si
l'histoire ne leur a pas rendu les mêmes
honneurs
chers collègues nous vivons actuellement
une époque troublée une guerre a lieu à
nos portes après qu'une pandémie est
déstabilisée durablement l'économie
mondiale
la crise énergétique est doublée d'une
crise climatique majeure une montée de
l'inflation un qui va être nos
concitoyens et l'incertitude la
tentation du repli sur soi et la peur
saisissent les populations
ce débat que nous avons aujourd'hui et
je remercie le gouvernement de l'avoir
organisé nous oblige à prendre en
considération la situation actuelle
mais en réalité la situation la question
est toujours la même comment conjuguer
le principe universel de la libre
circulation avec de l'autre côté le
principe du libre choix des peuples et
de leur gouvernance de disposer
librement de leur frontières
cet équilibre est difficile à trouver je
le conseille certains souhaitant la fin
irréaliste des frontières d'autres
voulant construire des murs tout aussi
illusoire entre les pays
nous devons à nos compatriotes de
métropoles et des Outre-mer de chercher
ce chemin d'équilibre les Français
attendent des réponses nous les savons
exigeants
la dernière loi que nous avons votée en
2018 a produit des résultats et à
entraîner une forte progression des
éloignements entre 2017 et 2019 avant la
crise du covid c'est mieux que ce que
font nos voisins européens mais
évidemment ce n'est pas suffisant c'est
la raison pour laquelle notre groupe
aborde le prochain projet de loi sur
l'immigration avec beaucoup de
pragmatisme mais aussi beaucoup
d'humanité pour le groupe démocrate
comme je l'avais dit en 2018 nous devons
avoir une politique d'immigration et
d'intégration à la fois humaine et
opérante parce que l'un ne va pas sans
l'autre c'est pour nous la clé d'une
législation réussie
sans ces deux bras pour accueillir chez
nous ceux qui ont besoin de notre
protection ceux qui sont une chance ou
un soutien pour notre activité
économique ce qui viennent s'enrichir de
nos savoirs et faire rayonner notre pays
à l'international sans cette action
exigeante nourrissons de renforcer la
défiance de certains de nos concitoyens
de réveiller des sentiments de rejet et
d'accentuer des fractures dans notre
société
la première réponse est européenne vous
l'avez indiquée madame la Première
ministre en effet une organisation
régionale telle que l'Union européenne
et a fortiori un état ne peuvent pas
espérer maîtriser seul les mouvements
migratoires les concernant ce qui
n'enlève rien à la nécessité de
politique nationale pertinente
l'exemple récent de l'océan vakking en
est une parfaite illustration les trois
semaines d'errance du navire qui a fini
par trouver refuge en France nous
rappelle qu'il faut impérativement
harmoniser les conditions d'entrée d'une
part mais aussi renforcer notre capacité
à mettre en œuvre les droits humains
d'autre part
pourtant en 2018 des lignes avaient été
tracées sur ce point je tiens à séduire
le travail riche et fourni de notre
groupe en particulier celui mené par
Marielle de Sarnez alors présidente de
la commission des affaires étrangères
qui rappelait alors à juste titre que la
stratégie que nous devons mener est
européenne diplomatique de développement
par le biais d'une vision à long terme à
cet égard elle encourageait un objectif
premier harmonisé nos pratiques
aujourd'hui cette convergence européenne
tant attendue de l'asile doit enfin être
mise en oeuvre sous forme de coopération
renforcée si nécessaire entre État
membre d'accord pour avancer ensemble
en matière de droit d'asile nous savons
tous que si le régime d'asile européen
commun fixe des normes minimales
communes au traitement des demandeurs
d'asile ces derniers ne font pas l'objet
d'un traitement uniforme et des taux de
reconnaissance varie d'un État membre à
l'autre cela entraîne une course au
droit d'asile qui montre combien
l'harmonisation des procédures et des
normes en matière d'asile nécessaire
en matière de partenariat global et
équilibré avec les pays d'origine et de
transit c'est une évidence notre gestion
des flux migratoires qui de soi qui doit
se faire à l'échelle européenne nous
impose de regarder au-delà de nos
frontières afin de permettre à ses
femmes ses enfants ses hommes qui fient
leur pays d'avoir le choix celui de
rester là où ils sont nés là où leur
famille est installée là où il leur
culture leur identité
à l'échelle nationale il est entre
autres indispensable que nous
poursuivions nos efforts pour réduire
les délais de traitement de la demande
d'asile c'est ainsi que nous permettrons
bénéficier de la protection
internationale de s'inscrire plus
rapidement dans un parcours
d'intégration sans perdre de temps et
c'est ainsi également que nous pourrons
dans le cas d'un rejet de la demande
opéré plus rapidement un retour effectif
des déboutés vers le pays d'origine
c'était l'objectif de la loi 2018 dont
il faut je crois interroger et évaluer
les résultats à l'aune également de sa
courte période d'application en effet
promulgué en 2018 cette loi n'a pu voir
ses effets qu'en 2019 2020 et 2021 étant
impactés par la crise de sanitaire comme
vous le savez ensuite il est essentiel
d'avoir une politique d'intégration
renforcée cela passe par l'acquisition
de la langue et par le travail François
Bayrou disait juste titre il y a
quelques jours qu'on devrait exiger deux
choses la maîtrise de la langue et de la
garantie de la volonté de s'intégrer de
participer un pays avec son mode de vie
et deuxièmement la volonté de s'engager
dans le travail pour gagner sa vie
aujourd'hui 75% des étrangers
signataires du contrat d'intégration
républicaine le SIR atteignent le niveau
requis à l'issue de la formation
obligatoire donnée par l'Office français
de l'immigration et de l'intégration
l'offi ce chiffre est bon même s'il est
encore insuffisant malgré tout la teinte
d'un niveau de langue n'est pas exigé
pour obtenir un titre de séjour la seule
obligation étant de suivre avec assudité
certes les formations civiques et
linguistiques organisées par Luffy dans
le cadre du contrat d'intégration
républicaine nous devons donc passer
d'une obligation de moyens à une
obligation de résultats il nous semble
nécessaire que le futur projet loi sur
l'immigration comporte des mesures
volontaristes en la matière
par ailleurs le travail doit de
redevenir le premier lieu de
l'intégration des étrangers quelle est
la situation aujourd'hui ça a été
rappelée par le ministre du Travail le
taux de chômage des immigrés et de 14,6%
contre 8,3 pour les personnes nées en
France et le taux d'emploi des immigrés
et seulement de 58,5% contre 66,4 pour
les personnes nées dans un dans le pays
en particulier je tiens à le signaler
pour les femmes avec un différentiel qui
va jusqu'à 15 points entre femmes
immigrées et femmes né en France
plusieurs dispositifs existent pour
favoriser l'intégration des réfugiés en
particulier le dispositif
d'accompagnement global et
individualiser des réfugiés mais
aujourd'hui trop de travailleurs
étrangers qui contribuent à l'économie
de notre pays sont installés et
maintenus dans le non droit où
l'illégalité ils ne peuvent pas dès lors
rejoindre un parcours d'intégration
c'est pourquoi je le dis avec force au
nom de mon groupe nous voulons que
l'hypogrisie cesse pour que ces trappes
à illégalité disparaissent il faut des
mesures pour que les travailleurs
étrangers eux-mêmes afin de faciliter
leur accès au travail dans des
situations bien définies et déterminées
et des mesures envers les employeurs
afin qu'ils participent mieux à l'état
gracion sociale de leur salarié cela
passe entre autres par des mesures de
régulation je pense notamment au secteur
des plateformes de transport et de et de
livraison par des réponses adaptées aux
métiers en tension aux besoins des
entreprises en matière de profil très
qualifiés et si nécessaire par des
sanctions dissuasives et appliquées en
cas d'emploi d'un étranger clandestin
né en 2005 le CZ le code de l'entrée et
du séjour des étrangers et du droit
d'asile peut-être le code le plus épais
de notre droit a connu de nombreux
toilettages depuis la fin des années 80
l'immigration a connu 21 lois 21 lois en
32 ans c'était certainement trop
reconnaissons le il existe très peu de
domaines dans lesquels on les GIF faire
autant
cela doit nous conduire à l'humilité je
crois quelle que soit notre place dans
l'hémicycle
monsieur le ministre vous entendez
aujourd'hui ouvrir une nouvelle page
vous avez choisi de mener plusieurs
chantiers renforcer notre efficacité
pour lutter contre les menaces à l'ordre
public et à l'immigration irrégulière
nous nous réjouissons que la lutte
contre les passeurs qui exploite la
détresse humaine en face partie engager
une réforme structurelle de notre
système d'asile en effet le traitement
des demandes d'asile est encore beaucoup
trop long et source d'un trop grand
contentieux sur ce point il est
important que les collectivités locales
soient des partenaires actifs et de
relais sans lequel les représentants de
sur lesquels les représentants de l'État
devront s'appuyer car sans l'échelle
locale rien ne se fera cependant il
faudra être attentif pour les OCC à ne
pas déséquilibrer le système en voulant
aller trop vite sans respecter les
droits du recours on appelle d'une
décision
vous entendez également renforcer les
exigences d'intégration par la langue et
le travail nos en sommes satisfaits je
le disais tout à l'heure il ne peut y
avoir d'intégration sans maîtrise de la
langue et un accès au travail sur tous
ces sujets nous aurons le temps de
travailler ensemble pour arriver à
l'équilibre et à l'efficacité car nous
croyons injuste équilibre celui-ci est
possible et nécessaire un humanisme
lucide adapté et exigeant c'est pourquoi
nous serons forts de proposition nous
veillerons à ce que nos valeurs soient
préservées l'accueil et l'intégration
nous pourront se faire qu'en étant
exigeant sur les modalités de mise en
oeuvre ce sont les seules clés d'une
acceptation par tous de notre devoir
d'accueil et ainsi d'un climat apaisé
dans notre pays où chacun pourra trouver
sa place
la migration n'est pas un phénomène dont
nous devons avoir peur elle existe
depuis la nuit des temps vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur ministre de l'Intérieur
qui d'entre nous n'a d'ailleurs pas un
parent un ami un collègue qui n'est pas
d'origine française qui d'entre nous ne
voient pas aussi combien la France a pu
s'enrichir de cette diversité alors
trouvons ensemble le courage de donner
les moyens à ceux qui ont toutes
légitimité à rester dans notre pays de
le faire dans les meilleures conditions
je vous remercie
je vous